official a live look here behind me that  is of course we've known that as the  Mirage well now it is officially  operated by Hard Rock International  Friday the Nevada gaming control board  approved the 1.1 billion dollar purchase  and eventually it'll look something like  that you can see renderings of the  property's future there's already some  changes happening inside the property  right now but that giant guitar-shaped  hotel to the Las Vegas Skyline that  you'll what you'll notice the most  officials say the changes won't happen  right away of course major construction  should begin by the end of next year for  now the property will operate as normal  just with a different name